Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number eight of my road to one bill
series. Today we are starting off with a
pretty good milestone. We're just about
to hit 70 range here at the G old sand
crabs. Uh we can finally upgrade to
black dragonhide which we're going to do
right away instead of waiting another
seven levels like we did last time. Uh
so there is 70 range. That's pretty
nice. Uh we're going for 75 range
eventually. Um but I think we're going
to leave it at 70 for now. Okay. So here
is the black dragon hide which is pretty
exciting. Uh, so we're going to equip
that and see what our range bonus
actually gotten up to. Uh, it should
give us another 10, I believe. Uh,
actually, we're missing our crossbow, I
think. Oh, no, our hat. The bandana. Oh
my god, we need to get a better hat.
This bandanna looks like
crap. God damn it. Okay. Well, anyway,
our range was uh 78 attack bonus at
least. And let's see what it gives us.
Uh yeah, looks like it's going to be
another 10 nine range bonus. And anyway,
pretty nice. So, for those who didn't
actually see my moneymaking guide that
was out most recently, I actually found
a really cool way to make a quite a
hefty amount of cash by just combining
maladiction shards into maladiction
wards as well as odium shards into odium
wards. Um, so you can see I have all the
shards here. We'll quickly add up how
much they are worth and how much the
maladiction uh ward is worth. when you
sell it. So, it's about 3,300 for the
malad addiction ward. And if you take
off the cost of all the shards, you're
still left with about
476k in profit, which is great. And you
don't need any actual skill requirements
for this. All you have to do is run into
the wilderness. I'll show you in a
minute here. Um, but uh it's a really
cool place, a really cool method, and
yeah, I'll do a quick overview of this
again. Yeah. So, all I did was pull the
lever uh to go into the wilderness. All
you need to bring is the malddiction
shards as well as a knife. And there
isn't much risk for this either because
uh like I said in the video, you're
going to protect three items. And
conveniently, it's only three pieces,
which is awesome. Uh so, you're just
going to run uh down south of here,
bring some food because you can
sometimes run into the chaos elemental
as well as if you're low level, those
dogs kill you. Uh so, just be a little
mindful of where you're going. If you
have done desert treasure, you can
actually take a much quicker route uh
using the Anac Carl teleport or somehow
whatever it's called. And uh but anyway,
just going to run along here, run along
the fence, and you're going to basically
the very top right portion of the map.
Uh if you want to watch the video, I'll
put a link in the description as well.
It'll go over the whole full thing.
Yeah. So, you can see here the chaos
elemental can kind of [__] you up a
little bit, but uh just kind of bring
some food or if you're really scared,
you can go on the other side of the
fence and run down. Uh, but I'm just
kind of lazy, so I just ran this way.
Uh, so we're almost here. I brought a
gold ring because there's a little
Easter egg you can do involving Lord of
the Rings, actually, which is probably
one of my favorite movies. Uh, actually
don't know if I can ramble much longer.
This takes about 2 minutes to go here.
Uh, but it's kind of hard to talk for 2
minutes about nothing. Anyway, but you
saw the entire path. So, you can run up
here to you see where that forge is?
Bring the shards and a ring if you want
to. doesn't really require it at all,
but toss the ring in the fire if you
want. And there we go. And you can see
Smeiggle actually jumps into the fire
for the ring. Uh, luckily you don't
actually lose the ring. But the whole
reason we're here is you're going to use
the maliction shard on the furnace or
the fire, sorry, and it forges it into a
maladiction ward for you. And it's
pretty sweet. That is 476k. And we'll
maybe do that a couple times. Okay, so
we sold the maliction ward for 3,300k,
which is quite nice actually. Leaves us
with about 475k in profit. Uh, and
considering it only took us 3 minutes to
run it over there, I would consider that
pretty time efficient. And yeah, so
we'll try to do this at least one more
time. Okay, so we sold another
maladiction ward. That is two. Uh, we
bought all the shards for the same
price. U, but that one we sold for a
little bit less, but that's still about
900k in total we made there, which is
awesome. On top of that, we bought these
compost potions, which are pretty cool.
Again, in my video, I go over this a
bit, but you just combine them into
super compost. Very easy. Uh I
personally just leave an offer in there
for quite a while cuz they do slowly buy
eventually. Uh even with the video
coming out, they are still coming
through. Okay, so I think uh we're just
going to go buying all these potions.
And uh sorry, I'm just tripping out. We
are done combining the potions is what I
mean. Uh the super compost have dropped
quite a bit uh to 660. But that being
said, we're still going to make about
400k from these super compost, I
believe. Maybe 350. And it only took me
about 20 minutes to combine them. So,
still quite a good money-making method.
Uh, I bought the the compost potion for
8.25. And yeah, we're selling the
compost for about 400k profit. So, not
bad. Okay, so these super compost
potions finally sold. Uh, didn't really
take that long at all. Probably a couple
hours. Um, but the compost potions did
take a while. That probably took 2 days
or something to buy the rest of those.
Uh, super combo have crashed quite a
bit. Uh, me and one other guy actually
made a video on it at the same time. So
anyway, we'll combine them at some
point. Okay, there is level 50 strength.
You may have seen it quickly there. Uh,
we just decided to get our combat stats
up a bit more cuz they were pretty low
and we were planning on doing monkey
madness pretty soon. And there we go.
We're just about to hit 50 attack as
well. Uh, we kind of had that prepared
already. So you might have seen her
already hit 49 uh attack, but still just
want to get on clip. So we're hit 50 and
then after that I think we're going to
go for 55 strength as then 60 attack or
60 or 59 attack maybe. Uh cuz we're
going to do monkey badness and it's
going to give us some attack and
strength experience. Um but we'll figure
that out in a minute. So 50 attack
pretty nice. Uh our combat levels up to
about 64 now. And yeah, I think we're
going to get our prayer level up to 43
pretty soon. Okay, so we actually have
some dragon bones just from canyoning
the dragons a bit. So, I think we're
just going to use the ones we have. And
I think that should be able to get us to
43 pretty easily. Uh because we want to
do the hard clue and having protect
melee is just essential. So, we have to
get it at some point. So, we might as
well do now. Okay. Wow. This guy's house
is really nice. Oh my
god. Wow. Okay. Well, anyway, we'll just
finish these bones here and get to 43.
Well, look, we already got a level, so
it really will only take a few minutes
here. And there we go. We're just about
to hit 43 prayer. So now we got uh all
the over top prayers which is pretty
nice. I mean I don't even know why it
took us this long but anyway protect
from me is pretty important. Okay so
we're back to the dark knight fortress.
Uh this is where we got completely
slayed last time. It doesn't seem super
dangerous. Uh but as soon as you run in
here it's a multi combat and there's a
ton of them and they just they wreck
you. So now that we have these uh
protect from melee prayer uh we can
easily do this. So we'll go continue our
clue. I'm not 100% sure if we'll be able
to do it. Uh but we'll do it as far as
we can. Uh, we're definitely missing
some of the requirements, though.
Unfortunately, I don't think I can do
this clue, so we'll have to leave it for
now. But it was still worth getting the
prayer levels. Now, I want to try
something I've been looking forward to
attempting for quite a while, and that
is cannoning elder chaos druids.
Apparently, you can get about 100k XP an
hour in range. Uh, so they're right
here, and yeah, let's give it a shot.
Okay, so we're here. Um, it's in the
wilderness, so it's kind of risky. So,
we risk cannonballs and the cannon you
shouldn't lose unless you have in your
inventory. Um, so yeah, let's see how
this works. The chaos druid special that
teleports you around is so annoying
though and it kind of gives me seizures.
Okay, so uh yeah, it's working pretty
well. So, we're going to buy some more
cannonballs and just head back there.
You can see my cannon's still there
getting me experience. Uh, so I think
we're going to bring a,000 cannonballs
at a time. Actually, we'll do 500 to
start with cuz we're definitely going to
get PKed. And there we go. I died and
we're just trying to get my stuff back
here. But my god, this is such a
cluster. [__] You can see all my stuff
plus more people stuff on the ground.
There's some PKers fighting here. The m
ah the the the chaos druids are just
teleporting me around. Maybe I can just
sneak my stuff back,
but Oh, this is awful. Look, that guy's
about to die. And he's dead, too. My
god. Okay, so in the end, he ended up
popping me down and killing me again. So
that was stressing me out. So, we came
back here to rock crabs for a little
bit. This train my meas, but we're going
to give a a bit more of a try a bit
later at night, I think. Uh, cuz right
now it's a little too much prime time
and people are pecing and it's so much
going on. It's almost impossible to know
when you're getting attacked anyway.
Okay, so yeah, we're back at Zancrabs.
We're going to give the elder chaos
druids another chance. Uh, but we're
going to wait a little bit cuz I do not
feel like dealing with that right now.
Uh, so there's 52 strength and we are
back and we're about to hit 53 strength.
Um, bad timing on the window there, but
anyway, we'll see. I'm not sure if we're
going to go for 55 right now. We're just
about to finish up a herb run. Then we
can probably sell those Renars, I think.
And yeah, I was right. This is the last
of our seeds in our bank. So, we'll just
finish this up and then we can go ahead
and sell them. Okay, so we are at the
Grand Exchange. We are going to
hopefully sell these for about a 800k
profit. We got 238, which is pretty bang
on the dot, pretty average. I'd say 200
is on the low end for 40 Renar seeds.
250. 300 would be very high. So, we're
about kind of smack dab in the middle.
So, we got about 800 game profit. And uh
like I said, we're going to go try the
elder chaos trids again. Hopefully, we
can make it the whole length without
dying, but I do not expect that to be
so. So, we'll buy 2,000 cannonballs and
see if we manage to use them all uh
before we die. Okay, so we used about a
thousand of the cannonballs so far, so
not too bad. I haven't seen a care here
yet. And yeah, we're getting about 80 to
90k experience an hour. Okay, we are
dead. Um, but you know, it happens. We
had about 200 cannonballs left, so I
don't know. Pretty happy with that, I
guess. Oh, I'm back here and there's
like three people around and there's
just crap on the ground. I'm trying to
grab my cannon, getting teleported
around. I'm getting frustrated as hell.
Just picked up a [__] fedora off the
ground. I don't even know what's going
on anymore. I just want my stuff and I
want to get out of here. All right, so
we managed to get most of my items back.
Uh they did not actually manage to pick
up much of my stuff and uh we did use
all the cannons. So we got about I
cannonball storage. We got about 70k
experience in about an hour, even less.
So honestly pretty good. I'm definitely
going to give another try. But it is
very very much cluster [__] Okay, we're
just finishing up our cockatric task. Uh
but we got 40 slayer which is pretty
nice. And we'll probably do a couple
more tasks today. I don't believe it.
We've actually got two mystic boot.
Mystic boot light are I guess what they
are. Um it's a one in 512 chance of
getting that. That is
stupid. Why do I have to get these? Why
can't I get anything better? All right,
the task is complete. So, we'll go ahead
and grab another one and uh yeah, see
how good it is. Okay, we're back at
Vanica and let's see what we get. 119
hob goblins. Really not too bad.
Uh, we'll definitely do those, but I
think we're going to leave that for now.
Okay, guys. I think that's where we're
going to call it for today's episode.
Uh, we're going to quickly tally up how
much money we have at the end of episode
8. Uh, we're use this collect feature,
which I almost never use. Uh, so we have
1.7 mil that we sold in Renard's. Um, I
some other random stuff. So, we've got
5.8 mil in cash. Um, I always always go
to that tab. 5.8 million cash. And yeah,
let's have a look at what we got. So, we
looking at about 6.7 mil. Getting close
to seven, uh, which I'm pretty happy
with. And I think it's going to go up
quicker from here. Again, some of the,
uh, malion ward got about a mill this
episode. We still have to make those
compost potions, which will get us like
another 600k. And our stats are getting
along pretty nicely. So, we'll hopefully
soon get to do some better combat
money-making methods, uh, or somewhat
skills. Um, either way, I'm glad you
guys stuck around episode 8. I hope you
enjoyed and I'll see you guys in the
next episode.
[Music]